On Monday, December 14, 1903, the Wright brothers
took the Wright Flyer out in their first attempt
to fly it.
The plane “flew” only for a few seconds,
stalling when Wilbur pulled up too sharply
as soon as the plane was in the air.
Three days later, after repairing the damage
done to the craft, Orville took his turn at
the controls and achieved a slightly more
successful flight, though he too underestimated
the elevator sensitivity, resulting in him
flying in something of a sinusoidal pattern
before crashing.
Before his “landing,” though, he managed
to fly the plane for about 12 seconds and
a distance of around 120 ft.
After minor repairs, the two took turns with
the longest flight of the day lasting 59 seconds
and covering 852 feet.
Unfortunately, the Flyer was damaged after
this flight.
Before the two could repair it for future
flights, a gust of wind came up and toppled
the craft, damaging it beyond immediate repair
(though it was many years later mostly repaired
for display in museums).
Whether these constituted the real first manned,
powered flights is up for debate.
Many people before this had developed successful
gliders (including the Wright brothers), some
developed successful powered craft (though
not manned), and there are a few others with
reasonably credible stories that claimed to
have created and flown manned, powered aircraft
before the Wright brothers.
Whether they were the first or not, what set
the Wright brothers’ craft apart from many
other claimants of the day was that their
craft was not only powered and capable of
carrying a person, but it was also fully controllable,
and the three-axis system they developed to
achieve this is not too dissimilar to the
way planes are controlled today.
As for the Flyer II, it was more or less the
same as the Flyer I except it was equipped
with a more powerful motor and made from a
different type of wood.
This flew 105 times and the brothers were
able to achieve flight times as much as five
minutes long, often showing off their innovative
control system via flying in full circles.
With the Flyer III, they did even better,
including one flight where Wilbur flew in
circles for 39 minutes straight for a total
distance of twenty-four miles on October 5,
1905.
By 1908, five years after they took their
legendary powered flight, the Wright brothers
were traveling all over the United States
and Europe demonstrating their fabulous flying
machine and taking various people up with
them in the demonstrations.
Everything went well-until September of that
year.
That was when Orville Wright was demonstrating
their machine at Fort Myers, Virginia.
At this time, the U.S. Army was interested
in purchasing aircraft from the Wright brothers.
It was the job of the younger Wright brother
to show how safe and practical their plane
was.
On September 10th, he took Lieutenant Frank
D. Lahm with him on a flight.
Two days later, Orville flew Major George
O. Squier around for 9 minutes.
These first two flights went swimmingly, but
the next was a catastrophe.
takeoffOn September 17, 1908, Orville Wright
took 26-year-old Lieutenant Thomas Selfridge
up for another demonstration.
A cheering crowd of an estimated 2,000 people
gathered to witness the flight.
Selfridge waved to the crowd as the plane
took off.
Wright flew a few laps over the parade ground
at approximately 150 feet without incident,
but then disaster struck.
In his own words,
On the fourth round, everything seemingly
working much better and smoother than any
former flight, I started on a larger circuit
with less abrupt turns.
It was on the very first slow turn that the
trouble began.
… A hurried glance behind revealed nothing
wrong, but I decided to shut off the power
and descend as soon as the machine could be
faced in a direction where a landing could
be made.
This decision was hardly reached, in fact
I suppose it was not over two or three seconds
from the time the first taps were heard, until
two big thumps, which gave the machine a terrible
shaking, showed that something had broken.
… The machine suddenly turned to the right
and I immediately shut off the power.
Quick as a flash, the machine turned down
in front and started straight for the ground.
Our course for 50 feet was within a very few
degrees of the perpendicular.
Lt. Selfridge up to this time had not uttered
a word, though he took a hasty glance behind
when the propeller broke and turned once or
twice to look into my face, evidently to see
what I thought of the situation.
But when the machine turned head first for
the ground, he exclaimed ‘Oh!
Oh!’ in an almost inaudible voice.
Under normal circumstances, Orville may have
been able to simply glide the plane in, but
unfortunately the broken propeller struck
the wire that was bracing the vertical rudder,
which is what caused the sudden nose dive.
Wilbur did manage to recover some semblance
of control in the end, but wasn’t able to
land the plane normally, hitting the ground
nose first and throwing the two passengers
forward in the wreckage.
Unfortunately for Selfridge, in the process,
his head struck a piece of the wood frame
of the airplane, cracking his skull.
Flyer_crashThe pair were soon extracted from
the wreckage and miraculously they were both
still alive, though a bit bloodied up.
But whereas Orville was still conscious, Selfridge
was not.
Both men were rushed to the nearby hospital
on stretchers and Selfridge was quickly operated
on.
Despite this, he didn’t make it, with the
official cause of death being listed as complications
due to a fractured skull.
And so it was that Thomas Selfridge gained
the dubious honor of being the first person
to die in an airplane crash.
He was subsequently buried with military honors
at Arlington National Cemetery (which by the
way has a surprisingly fascinating history).
It is generally thought that had he been wearing
a helmet, he likely would have survived the
crash as the rest of his injuries, while non-trivial,
were not considered life-threatening.
Because of his death, when the army started
sending pilots up in planes, they required
that they wear thick headgear for protection.
As for Orville, he escaped death, but did
suffer a broken left leg, fractured and dislocated
hip, several broken ribs, cuts on his head,
and bruises all over his body.
After about a month and a half in the hospital,
he was released on October 31st.
Although he was to walk and fly again, he
did suffer pain from the fractures to his
hip for the rest of his life, which turned
out to be a long one.
While his brother, Wilbur, died just four
years after this incident, in 1912, Orville
made it all the way to 1948, getting a chance
to see the airplane industry go from a couple
of bike mechanics in an empty field to a form
of transport that came to dominate long distance
travel and became essential in various military
exploits, the latter of which Orville was
not at all happy about.
He stated after WWII,
We dared to hope we had invented something
that would bring lasting peace to the earth.
But we were wrong….No, I don’t have any
regrets about my part in the invention of
the airplane, though no one could deplore
more than I do the destruction it has caused.
I feel about the airplane much the same as
I do in regard to fire.
That is I regret all the terrible damage caused
by fire, but I think it is good for the human
race that someone discovered how to start
fires and that we have learned how to put
fire to thousands of important uses.